Hey how's its going bros!
and welcome to saske and friends
15  (12 year old anime music)
*music*
(Poods Happy) (dem titties)
(Oh DAMN)
clearly i need to step up my haircut for this
video, what do you think. it needs to be
good ( sprays water )
and then up, oh yeah
p put em face to face
(Yeah, you look alike... I'm serious)
(no im not)
alright
here we go
wait, we're pushing the car?!
We're pushing the...
we're pushing the car...?!
*akward silence*
*weird stare*
PUSH!!!!!!!!!!!!
aww!
Yeah!
push the car!
Now this, this is gameplay
Keep Pushing
Oh we're pushing, and we're pushin
And we're pushing some more
That's right lads keep pushing
Oh...Oh...
What is? Oh... Oh no
There is a car guys
Ohhhhhhh!! Oh! Oh!
(Poods singing)"Darling stand"
Is that a rhino? (yes and that rhino will shove its horn up your a$$)
Wow
You know what
This game takes like 200 hours to beat
and im starting to understand why
I need a break, that was way too much effort
In this one you can fish
Wow Lets do it
Wow
Had it ready... ok
Lets do it
(Poods puzzled)
(Still Puzzled)
What ?
Oh , i see. Alright here we go
There 's a fish
There's a fish here
There it is
Oh oh oh oh oh oh
It's getting intense
WHAT THE F***
OH
Oh
AAHH!
C'mon
Tilt
Tilt Dammit
The tension...the tension
Ugh...Press to reel in the fish
AAHH!
C'mon
This is the most intense fishing in my life
(Poods annoying reading)
Fish dont fly
Japan
But thank you
Do you have to say it so dramatically
Shut the f**k up
I'm F**king  fishing over here
Dammit
*Headphones fall off*
Never fishing again
Dont look at me
Hey let's all sleep here guys
Yeah! Awww
Look, it's great
This game is literally just a bunch of bros on the road, its awesome
Hey, why dont ya
Why dont you stay out here with me buddy
Hey look they got a table
I love table
Guys, there's like a kitchen in here
So anyway when i got that fish, i was like DAMN
This fish is staint like that pussy
Sorry im sorry, sorry
Hey guys when im talking about pussy
Dont even get me started on Sakura's
HAHA
(Poods laughing)
This game really makes me feel like i have freinds
I really appreciate that... Thank you game
Hey guys why are we walking
WHEN WE CAN RIDE BIRDS
Oh my god, this is amazing
What is this game about
(poods chuckles)
Just a bunch of bros hanging out, riding on their birds, whatever
Ok, here we go, FAST!
Hey how you doin' baby
Hey, i see your... i see you, th..., you match my bird
I hate being single
Can you get a drink ?
Gotta f*** you up real good
You're not gonna walk straight
Alright, sounds great!
Yeah, thats damn fu**in' right
Yeah, I bet you wanna look at my abs dont ya ?
*High-Pitched* YEAH!
Yeah you can look,
Its alright
They're rock hard (like something else ;) )
(Sniffs)
Alright, well lets keep going
Let's keep going i suppose
OH OH
Oh Oh
OH Shit, what is happening ?
What the heck wo ho !
Hey eh, cleavage
Hello !
JAPAN !
Oh, hold.. hold,  i'll show what i can do
Four guys one girl , i swear i've seen this somewhere else.
(WE KNOW)
That was p69n joke everyone
Shit, I just almost, i think i just died
Oh no
*Bursts a chuckle*
It's so cheesy !
She called me pretty !
(You are we think)
C'mon i cant pee if you guys watch
It's been a long day
I'm tired... I'm exhausted
I th... I think its time to go to bed
What do you boys say ? (YES)
Oh Yeah
That was Final Fantasy Fifteen
Saske and friends edition
Oh you enjoyed, if you did
Go ahead and leave a like
Now im gonna stay with ma boys and have some fun
(Winks, Imagining wild things)
(Claps 2x) Alright, thank you bros for watching
and as always, stay awesome
(SUBSCRIBE TO POODS)
(And Fire8812)
(WISH HIM LUCK)
(#Pewds60Million)
( He Deserves it )
(BROFIST)